good morning I'd like to reconvene the
governor's budget hearing
and the first uh one out of the dock is
Secretary of State and I'd like to
invite the Secretary of State up for his
budget testimony
good morning
secretary
I'm Secretary of State David Scanlon and
with me is deputy secretary Aaron
Hennessey
excuse me
yeah
the budget that we are proposing is
straightforward it follows the
guidelines sent forth by the governor
it does include uh five new positions
um two of them are related to
information technology and three are
clerical
um you know really no other initiatives
that are new in the budget we we do have
an election presidential primary coming
up in FY 20.
for
eign
that that election is typically funded
uh in a budget footnote and I understand
those are going to be addressed later
but we want to make sure that we have
the funds available to conduct that
election
um I really don't have anything to add
to that other than to answer any
questions that you might have
okay thank you
uh over the last month now or close to a
month we the state has undergone a
number of well-publicized recounts uh
how are those accounted for in the
budget and maybe I could say like how
expensive is a typical recount to your
office and then how is that accounted
for in the budget when when you have uh
recounts that maybe you're above and
beyond your expectations
uh the recounts are paid for out of the
elections portion of our budget
excuse me the candidates that request a
recount
pay a fee
based on how close the race was if it
was a very close race
the fee is nominal and the state
basically picks up the cost
if and then depending on the percentage
the fee gets progressively higher
excuse me
if the difference between winning and
losing is more than three percent then
the candidate has to agree to pay for
the cost of the recap
that cost involves picking up the
ballots from the various municipalities
um
for the district that is being recounted
and then hiring
I'm sorry
and then hiring the teams uh the
counting teams necessary to conduct a
recount and we have a pool of
probably 30.
counters that we use through the course
of the election
this year has has been a record and we
still we're still in the final recount
so we're close to a month after the
election and we're still recounting
ballots so the cost of three counts is
going to be higher than it typically is
okay thank you uh
this year I believe you have a total of
80 funded positions
and as much a good chocolate of those 80
positions how many are currently staffed
or which in other words what what's your
vacancy rate do you want to address it
yeah let's see
we have roughly seven vacant positions
um four of those are
excuse me I.T
uh you know we have been trying to fill
those uh and we're having the same
struggles uh like every other agency in
terms of trying to find people to apply
for the positions and take the job okay
and in the new positions what it what
what's the basis for those what are
their what's their job responsibility is
going to be
excuse me the secretary of state is one
of the few agencies that has an
independent information technology
division uh we have that because of the
importance of making sure that our
elections primarily are independent from
any other agency in it
we control those databases
um and so we own the responsibility for
that
um
the positions that we are trying to fill
are our top leadership positions
um
their their management
and database related
okay thank you
um
I think that answers my questions thank
you very much
um you had mentioned that normally
there's a budget but no
um
that's included for in regards to the
primary can you just talk a little bit
about what that is and what the dollar
amount if there is one that's in that
footnote of how much uh I'm going to ask
Paul if she can give me that number
and it's for conducting the presidential
the state primary and the general and to
fund the election a Bud's position the
attorney
the amount is nine hundred thousand
dollars uh and that funds the
presidential primary
and a legal position that we have uh for
the elections
within the Department of State
is that legal position currently funded
I mean it's our currently filled it's
currently filled and funded and uh the
the occupant is Bud Fitch okay
[Music]
okay that's all I have
okay thank you normally we would say
thank you very much for your testimony
but uh you're still on the dock uh we're
going to switch you now to the right to
know Ombudsman obviously it's a new
position which I don't believe has been
filled yet uh in a new office but
um not take your testimony on that
the um
go ahead yep
sure so just for background if you're
not aware this was a legislative
um position that was created in the last
term and it was attached to the
Secretary of State's office my
understanding is that the governor and
Council and the governor have not
um
approved uh or found the person for this
position yet but once this position is
filled by the governor and Governor
Council it will be the person will be
located somewhere within our office and
attached to us and do you want me to go
over what the budget is for that yes
please
so it's one position
and
the total estimated funding for this
position is 129 217 dollars
and that's in 24. and 136 797 and 25.
and and the source of payment is general
fund revenues
yes it is okay
thank you very much
thank you
we're good
thank you thank you and yeah okay
uh boxing and wrestling Commission
invite you now to take for your
testimony
hi good morning
um good morning wrestling commission
um is attached to the Secretary of
State's Department we provide them with
the just administrative clerical support
that they need
um Bobby Stevens who's the chair of the
commission for Gretzky can't be here
today he's away
um their budget is strictly an
efficiency budget from this current
budget year their expenses are really
mostly only per diems for the board
members to attend the events mileage for
that and a small stipend for them to
attend the yearly meeting of the
National Committee
and their budgets are around roughly
seven thousand dollars in each in each
fiscal year
for the first time in three days I don't
have a question
that's good because I don't know much
about boxing itself
thank you so much
thank you very much you're welcome
hey
now I like to invite the judicial
Council
for their budget testimony
sure thank you
good morning
good morning is this I'm sorry is this
on that is on that the red light's on
it's you're good that makes sense
um good morning I'm Sarah Blodgett
executive director of the judicial
Council and I am here with Richard
samparrell who I anticipate will shortly
be appointed as the acting executive
director of the judicial Council my last
official day with the council is
tomorrow and that has nothing to do with
the budget process it just worked out
that way
um but I wanted to um make sure that you
all had a chance to meet Richard face to
face
and I expect that he will be uh
nominated in the next couple of days I'm
sorry appointed
um so we are in front of you today with
the most significant increase in the
history of the judicial Council and this
is necessary to address the ongoing
Indigent defense crisis
the vast majority of our additional
prioritized need which is a little over
14.5 million dollars is to fund
court-appointed representation
we are grateful for governor sununu and
the legislature's support of indigent
defense needs during this biennium
we have had a lot of help from allies
across the state as we deal with what is
really an unprecedented issue facing our
system
as you know the council is charged with
overseeing the quality and the cost
effectiveness of indigent defense and
those are duties that are taken very
seriously by the councils and its
members
that is reflected I think in our past
budget requests this is not an agency
that routinely asks for significant
increases in its appropriation
um
but we are here to do that now
we are at a Crossroads for Indigent
defense
I want to be clear that funding alone
will not solve these issues but without
it I do not see a path forward for our
criminal justice system
the state's funding for Indigent defense
fulfills the Constitutional requirement
to provide criminal representation to
those who cannot afford it
the public defender is the backbone of
our Indigent defense program and our
additional prioritized need requests for
this program is
just north of three million dollars
I want to give you a little bit of
history about the public defender uh in
a typical year this program handles 85
percent of the Indigent defense caseload
we have a group of private attorneys who
have contracts with the judicial Council
to take a certain number of cases for a
flat fee and those lawyers routinely
accept 14 of the caseload we also have a
pool of private attorneys who take cases
they are reimbursed on an hourly basis
and they in the past have accounted for
one percent of the Indigent defense
caseload
and those numbers are are really
critical to the success of the Indigent
defense program
in fiscal 22 for a variety of reasons
the public defender was only able to
handle 80 percent of the caseload now
that's only a decrease of five percent
but it almost broke the Indigent defense
program that we have here
um High staff turnover and case backlogs
created a perfect storm for the public
defender program
fewer cases resolved during the pandemic
leading to overwhelming caseloads many
lawyers were carrying more than 100
cases and I would like to just point
your attention to page one of our
handout
hopefully you got a beautiful color copy
um and I think that this really
illustrates where we are right now in
terms of
the knowledge base at the public
defender we still have a lot of
experienced qualified lawyers on that
program
but since the pandemic started you can
see that we lost a little less than 50
Attorneys at the public defender office
and you can see in the second column the
combined years of experience that those
attorneys represent that's 443 years of
experience with the public defender
program
the program during that same period of
time has been able to recruit and hire
55 lawyers the vast majority of those
lawyers came in with no experience and
so you can see in that final column what
the combined experience gained from
those hires has been and I think that
that really
really highlights our current struggle
right now
I think it's fairly obvious that new
lawyers are new members of any
profession are just not as efficient
they don't understand the system as well
there's a very steep learning curve for
new public defenders and the public
defender invests significantly in
training of new lawyers but it is going
to take a at least a few years for these
brand new lawyers to be up and running
at the level of some of the folks who
have Departed the program
this shift in experience is coincided
with increasingly complex cases
um
and the second page of our handout is
an illustration of the data requirements
for Discovery and you can see we're
showing you per office breakdown
and since 2018
the size terabyte size of Discovery
coming into the public defender has
increased dramatically and not only does
that mean costs for I.T and support for
it but it means that these cases take
much longer to resolve we have attorneys
who now have to look at dash cam video
footage and you know everybody it seems
as if everybody has a ring camera up and
so there's so much more evidence
potential exculpatory evidence that has
to be combed through and so a case that
might have taken 12 hours to resolve
five years ago could now take upwards of
40 hours just because of the amount of
evidence that needs to be reviewed by
Council
so there there's been a seismic shift in
the experience level of the staff
attorneys
clients are presenting with more
challenging issues I think it has become
increasingly clear that during the
pandemic many New Hampshire residents
were not getting mental health substance
use treatment and so the clients are
presenting a much more challenging
fashion than they had prior to the
pandemic
cases are also taking longer to resolve
and for the first time in its history
the public defender has been forced to
put clients on a hold list
the most recent count has 960 916 cases
awaiting appointment of counsel
there has been a recent change in
leadership at the public defender Sarah
Rothman who was the managing attorney of
the Manchester office one of the busiest
offices or probably the busiest office
in the state has taken over is the
executive director
she is focused on Recruitment and
Retention and our additional prioritized
need reflects these priorities
this appropriation would allow us to
continue the 10 increase that was
implemented on a temporary basis in
April of this year that was an across
the board increase in the salaries for
all staff
it would also allow the public defender
to fund additional steps at the top of
the scale so the original salary scale
ended at a step 11. this would allow the
public defender to fund steps 12 through
15 in an effort to keep the experienced
attorneys in the program
it would also fund an additional five
percent increase during the next
biennium
and in looking at advertisements for
public defender positions in neighboring
states
advertisements for positions with
prosecutor offices these salary
increases are really necessary to remain
competitive and to keep the folks that
we have now on board
it would also fund the creation of eight
new I.T paralegal positions which are
really critical especially in light of
this high volume Discovery cases and the
electronic discovery that is now common
and it would also be used to assist to
fund I.T upgrades
this additional prioritized need is the
number one priority for the judicial
Council we've had a glimpse over the
past couple of years of what will happen
if the public defender is not able to
keep 85 percent of its caselope 85
percent of the Indigent defense caseload
and our system is not built to address
that
Council has
struggled quite a bit over the past year
and a half with a point of counsel
outside of the public defender program
and
we are also in the I'm sorry the request
for the public defender is on page 14 of
the budget book
um and that request also includes four
million dollars for a secondary public
defender program
the council has had statutory authority
to create another program since the
1980s this is never had to seriously
contemplate this before
but right now we need another program
that will accept every case that is
offered to it absent a conflict or case
load caps
current Indigent defense system is not
meeting the need attorneys are
overwhelmed and they do not want to
accept incarcerated clients juvenile
clients or parole cases
today as I said here 14 defendants are
in jail awaiting appointment of counsel
we have three juveniles with upcoming
court dates but no attorney
so we are requesting four million
dollars to create another public
defender program that would be
it would be taking conflict cases
it could also help if there's still a
hold list at the time that it gets up
and running but the real need is to
ensure quick appointment of counsel
under the current program we are
reaching out to 25 attorneys to find
somebody who is willing to accept an
incarcerated client these delays are
increasing and we need to change the
program to respond to the need
uh the RFP will go out in the spring
obviously contingent on appropriate
funding through the budget
four million dollars is the best
estimate that we have for the cost of
setting up a firm from scratch but it's
certainly possible that an already
existing private firm will will put in a
proposal for this but we are looking to
focus on Merrimack in Hillsborough
County which have the most cases in the
state and we're the biggest unmet need
is right now
um the contract attorney budget is on
page 13 of the budget book
we are requesting an additional
prioritized need of six hundred thousand
dollars for this program
the contract attorneys are also in
crisis we have lost nine attorneys since
the beginning of fiscal 22 and that
equates to about 900 cases
so our contract attorneys are at maximum
capacity right now
the fiscal 23 contract included some
additional
reimbursements to the contract attorneys
we are now providing an administrative
fee to address overhead and we are
providing an additional two hundred
dollar fee for an incarcerated felony
case an additional hundred dollar fee
for an incarcerated misdemeanor level
case and the additional prioritized need
of six hundred thousand dollars is to
cover those costs
the assigned Council line is on page 11
of your of the budget book and this line
pays for the representation of indigent
defendants in criminal cases and accuse
parents in the child protection cases
at the request of the judicial Council
the Supreme Court increased the
reimbursement rate for court appointed
representation
the 60 an hour rate was set in 1992 and
it did not increase until October 1st of
this year when it went up to ninety
dollars an hour
the reimbursement rate for serious
felonies had been a hundred dollars an
hour and that rate it has increased to
125 dollars an hour
again as as we've seen that the public
defender had to curtail intake of new
cases the contract attorney program got
saturated the assigned Council who in
the past have only handled one percent
of this caseload that has increased to
six percent
and it is an increase of almost a
thousand more cases than in the previous
fiscal year every one of those cases is
assigned by calls emails and some cases
begging attorneys to take those
appointments and our materials include
some articles that discuss the the
crisis and the efforts that have been
made to address it as you know the
Supreme Court pulled together a task
force led by Justice Donovan they made a
request to private firms across the
state to take these cases we have
recruited attorneys from Massachusetts
Vermont Maine
but we still do not have enough lawyers
willing to accept these cases and since
the increase I have heard from attorneys
in private practice that this will help
them make a case to their Partners to
the partners that they should be able to
take some of these cases but we're still
not reimbursing at a level that is
anywhere near equivalent to the private
reimbursement rates
the additional prioritized need here is
uh quite steep at 3.6 million dollars
that is to fund the increase and the
reimbursement rates
Services other than Council are on page
15 of the budget book
um the council only pays for services if
a judge has determined that it is
necessary for an adequate defense as
required by the Constitution
this line includes costs for expert
Witnesses transcripts and interpreters
we almost expended the entire fiscal 23
appropriation for services by the end of
this month
uh our additional prioritized need is
1.5 million dollars
this also reflects an anticipated
significant cost for experts in the YDC
cases I'm sure you've seen some of the
headlines about these cases but the
discovery is in excess of 20 million
Pages there are 11 co-defendants and it
is a case unlike anything we have ever
seen before in this state and it is
going to be the cost is going to be
significant
and now I know that our handouts and and
most of my presentation today are
focused on Indigent fence and that is a
topic that we have talked about quite a
lot over the past several months but the
judicial Council also funds other
programs and we pay for the
private Guardians at Litem and the
attorneys appointed to represent parents
in the child protection world and the
judicial Council also contracts with
Casa
as I'm sure most of you know Casa is the
preferred provider of guardian ad litem
services and child protection cases
their volunteer Advocates receive
extensive training and supervision
the state's investment is a
public-private partnership and it funds
a relationship with abused or neglected
children that is just not possible under
the private reimbursement model
in fiscal 22 Casa Advocates spent over
89 000 hours on their cases they drove
over 460 000 miles and they had more
than 15 000 visits with their children
under the new reimbursement rates of
ninety dollars an hour that time
commitment alone would cost the state
over 8 million dollars
the cases coming to Casa and the
children coming to Casa have become
increasingly complex
during the pandemic reports of suspected
abuse and neglect were
delayed when children were not in school
and not being seen by other people in
the community
once those reports were made there is a
delay in the services because of the
workforce shortage that we're all facing
and so Casa is working with children who
have levels of trauma that are really
unbelievable
um
in fiscal 19 Casa worked with 52
children who had lost a parent
in fiscal 22 that number increased to
108 children who had lost a parent
in the past year Casa spent an average
of 262 hours per case and had 44 visits
with the children involved
because of the increased complexity
causes small legal staff has had to be
involved in more and more of these cases
they're now working in almost a third of
all child protection cases coming into
casa
we are requesting a two hundred thousand
dollar increase
this funding would be used to address
the workforce shortage
increased need for legal Staffing and
the continued Recruitment and Retention
of the volunteers that help Casa
function
our budget line 1101 is for the non-casa
Guardians at litem
um again they are assigned when Casa is
unavailable but uh Casa have bends over
backwards to make their Advocates
available and on numerous occasions
judges will reach out and say this case
needs a casa and Marty and her group
always step up and make that happen
for the cases where Casa is unavailable
and there has not been a request private
Guardians step up and fill that need our
additional prioritized need of 250 000
is a reflection of the increase in the
reimbursement rate from 60 to 90 dollars
the guardian ad litem fund which is
1092. it also covers the cost of private
Guardians and Litem in the termination
of parental rights cases that follows a
child protection case where the parent
has not been able to correct
pay for attorneys on guardianship of
minor and incapacitated adults out of
this line
and I think it's important to also note
that there's recent legislation that
authorizes the judicial Council to pay
for the services other than Council on
these cases and we expect that that will
increase our costs as well
as I think most of you are aware the
judicial Council serves as the
pass-through for the state's commitment
to the Civil legal needs of indigent
residents through an appropriation to
New Hampshire legal assistance
our additional prioritized need of 750
000 for this program would focus on New
Hampshire legal assistance and domestic
violence advocacy project
the domestic violence advocacy project
was founded over 20 years ago to provide
civil legal aid to survivors of domestic
violence sexual assault stalking and
human trafficking
nhla attorneys represent survivors and
protective order hearings and related
family law matters
these staff members work collaboratively
with the staff at the domestic violence
crisis centers across the state and the
vast majority of clients at nhla are
referred by the crisis center advocate
right now nhla attorneys represent
clients across the state
but there is not sufficient Staffing to
accept every case
their focus is on assisting survivors
who are at high risk of lethal violence
the judicial branch recently issued a
report from its task force on domestic
violence cases and that report noted
that less than 15 percent of survivors
have representation at a protective
order hearing
nhla is committed to this crucial work
they've received Voca grants and
vawa I'm not sure if that's vawa but
that's what I would I apologize for that
um they've received funding as well from
the legal assistance for victims grants
this additional prioritized need would
support between five and six new staff
attorneys who would be solely focused on
this work and would significantly
increase the representation for
survivors at a critical time in their
lives
I'm happy to take any questions
okay thank you for your testimony
we're going to go back pre-pandemic and
specifically about the the Indigent
Council uh how would you describe what
I'm trying to find out is
how much of this is is covert related
and how much is a long-term problem that
needs to be addressed
prior to say in 2019 the early part of
2020 fiscal year 2020. how would you
describe the program then compared to
now
thank you for the question up
prior to the pandemic we were seeing an
increase in the time to disposition for
criminal cases
and we actually
invited the sixth amendment Center here
to do an assessment of our Indigent
defense program and a large
part of that request was to help us
determine why cases were taking longer
to resolve
uh and we we did not get an answer to
that uh important question but it does
seem that there are a a number of
factors that have played into that I
think that we even before the pandemic
the effects of the opioid crisis were
complicating factors that both defense
counsel and prosecutors and the courts
we're dealing with
we also saw
um
some changes in the procedures at the
court
the switch to e-filing and and some
other changes that made the court system
perhaps more efficient but change the
way the defense Council was interacting
with the cases and that has I think
especially by more experienced attorneys
I think that that switch was difficult
so we had the opioid crisis we had some
changes to court procedure
and I think that
cases had been the the backlog had been
creeping up before the pandemic for
those reasons
you know five six seven years ago
the public defender had
had a really reached equilibrium in
terms of open and closed cases so if
they brought in 27 000 new cases during
the course of a year they were closing
roughly the same amount of cases but
that started to shift prior to the
pandemic and so certainly the pandemic
I think
was the the final straw if you will but
looking back we saw that the pieces were
coming into place that would lead to
this where we are right now okay thank
you uh in the article in your handout
you passed I believe it's in the Concord
Monitor it states that there were 32
attorneys departed over a 15-month
period
uh and and from your other from your
other charts they were very experienced
attorneys I wonder if you could just if
you had anecdotal evidence on why they
all left was it did they retire did they
just fed up with the job the pay wasn't
enough what was the overriding reasons
yeah I I think what we've heard and I
can certainly ask Sarah Rothman to speak
in more detail about this but it is
again it's been a combination of factors
the the packages available through
private practice uh over the past few
years have been exceptionally high and
we lost attorneys to Private Practice in
New Hampshire we've lost attorneys to
public defender programs in other states
especially Massachusetts
cpcs pays attorneys a much higher rate
and it also has a much lower caseload
cap and so it's been hard to keep
attorneys who have the opportunity to
make more money and have fewer cases
perhaps just south of our border
we also have seen attorneys starting
their own private practice and I think
that there has been a level of burnout
not just in this profession but in many
professions since the pandemic when
there were outbreaks and covet outbreaks
in the jails across the state many
attorneys from both the contract and the
public defender program
had to actually make life or death
decisions about whether to go visit a
client if they had underlying health
issues if they lived with a family
member who had underlying health issues
so I think that this job has become much
more challenging during the course of
the pandemic and overall we are seeing
that fewer and fewer attorneys Who come
out of law school with significant debt
are interested in public sector jobs
how confident are you that the what what
the packages you're proposing here will
be sufficient to bring in the attorneys
that you desperately need for this
program that's a very good question so
as you can see we've lost quite a few
experienced public defenders from that
from the program that we have
um I have had conversations with a few
former public defenders who tell me that
they are interested in working with an
alternative public defender program
um they are folks who have more
experience and I think could create a
more Nimble program of attorneys that
are able to take on the serious felonies
incarcerated cases and perhaps be a
model where we don't have the mentoring
and the training that happens in the
public defender office but we're really
focused on experienced lawyers who can
handle a higher volume of more serious
cases so I do think that you know the
workforce shortage is absolutely a
reality and that has played a
significant role in the crisis but I
believe that there are attorneys who are
experienced and still committed to
Indigent defense who may be willing to
do this work in a different capacity
okay one last question from me uh we in
in the budget you have significant
increases in the public defender program
the contract counseling the assigned
Council
uh Devil's Advocate question do we need
to do all three
for example if we fully funded the the
public defender program and it it worked
the way you you think it's going to work
you know can we keep the other two the
assigned Council and the contract
Council fairly close to where they are
now
I think is the million dollar question
um so multi-million dollars
yes
um so I think that right now we have the
the worst situation possible we have a
public defender that cannot take the
percentage of cases it used to take we
have a contract attorney program that's
not able to take the Overflow and then
we have private attorneys who have never
been
expected or resourced to take the
Overflow from that and so I think that
in the next biennium we will have
increased costs for all of these
programs but if there is a secondary or
alternative public defender program I
think that our Reliance on assigned
council is going to decrease
significantly and it won't happen right
away but we will not have the need to
reach out to 20 attorneys for an
incarcerated client if we have another
firm that is ready willing and able to
take every case that comes in
um so I think I see increased costs
during the next biennium but if we are
fully funded I believe that our assigned
Council costs will decrease dramatically
and the contract attorney program has
had natural attrition it's still a very
vital important part of our Indigent
defense system but I do not anticipate
that there's going to be any meaningful
increase in the lawyers willing to enter
into the contract attorney program okay
thank you I know the judicial Council
has lost a lot of a lot of people over
the last few years but the the biggest
loss they've they are going to suffer is
when you leave uh you are there's their
strongest Advocate and you will be
missed thank you for your service thank
you so much I really appreciate that
I couldn't agree with that more
um I'm going to ask James this question
just a little differently and I have to
one is
um if there's limited funding available
and we can't fully fund all the
prioritized needs is it better to fund
one one or two of the projects or
proposals that you have in its entirety
or spread out that amount of money a
little bit in each area you know as
example instead of saying I'm and I'm
gonna I don't know the exact numbers but
three million just to the public
defender
um you know a million here 250
if you didn't have a full you know could
do a full three million to public
defender and nothing of something else
or is it better to say I'll give them
each half a million like what would work
better if you had to choose in terms of
those scenarios that's a that's a tough
question but what we have seen and what
I believe will continue to be true is
that the public defender has got to be
fully funded
um I think
I I cannot emphasize enough what a
crucial role that program plays and even
just a 12-month period of the public
defender not being at full capacity has
had a devastating effect
okay
um and then a separate question is I
know that you have the ability to to
reach into funds not otherwise
appropriated when the budget is not
sufficient and the budget of around 30
million that's there does that for
example in 22 include those dollars from
funds not always appropriated or if it
doesn't how much extra had you had to go
and ask for so for
I'm not sure if this is
um if I'm responding to the question but
our request for
all of the budget lines the assigned
Council the services those are the no
are real numbers those are the numbers
that we expect we will need to get
through the next biennium
um and so it does not anticipate going
back to the fiscal although I know they
love it when we do yeah
um but these are numbers to fully fund
all of our budget lines do you um have
any guesstimate or estimate on in the
last fiscal year what you had to go back
to fiscal for
so the last fiscal year is is tricky
because we went back for the public
defender program which you know is very
rare we received an additional 2.4
million dollars uh for the public
defender program we had to go back for
services other than Council and assigned
Council
um and I will give you the exact numbers
I apologize I don't I don't have those
right here and I should
um but really the the biggest unmet need
in the appropriation that we received
for this biennium is Services other than
Council and we had requested an
additional prioritized need of just shy
of five hundred thousand dollars for
those expenses uh but even that estimate
ended up being low I mean we'll we'll
need about this year we'll need almost
double the appropriation
for services all right thank you
thank you very much thank you so much
I'd like to invite Health and Human
Services for their testimony
foreign
commissioner yes we are
good morning my name is Lori shibanad
I'm the Commissioner of Health and Human
Services I am joined today by Lori
Weaver Deputy Commissioner and Nathan
white the CFO of the department being
said I am
very close to being done with my tenure
I am going to give the lead to both
Nathan and Lori for the budget hearing
but I am present to answer questions if
I can thank you
morning Nathan white Chief Financial
Officer of the Department of Health and
Human Services I'm here with you today
to present the state fiscal year 2425
DHHS agency budget request
and I I uh we're going to be covering
things at a pretty high level I think I
chalked it down about 160 million
dollars a minute given the time frame so
we will be going through through things
rather quickly I won't be covering
everything but we will touch on some
highlights so on page two of the
document that I have in front of you
there's a high level agenda and we're
going to first just kind of touch on
Mission Vision or Mission
responsibilities caseload organization
Staffing and then get into the
efficiency budget request as well as
some of the prioritized needs
on page three
um you see laid out there the mission of
the department which to join communities
and families and providing an
opportunity for citizens to achieve
health and Independence and this really
comes down to meeting the basic health
needs of basic human needs of our
citizens and protecting the the most
vulnerable
on page four uh there is a high level uh
overview of some of the responsibilities
of DHHS that are statutorily required of
us to educate the public and providers
on navigating complex systems of care I
think you know Medicaid typically comes
to mind Medicaid to schools things of
that nature as well as the next bullet
there delivery of services to clients
and we do this through our district
offices which are located across the
state where we provide Direct Services
to the citizens of New Hampshire we have
contracted community-based organizations
at any point in time the department may
have anywhere from 500 to 800 live and
active contracts some of those may be
with non-profits within the community
some of those may be with more of the
I.T related contracts or by direct
support to the department to support our
systems
they're they're below that you'll see
the client services call center where I
think you know when you think of like
New Hampshire easy or something like
that where we help people get signed up
for various benefits and then below that
there is also Direct Care
um DHHS has a number of Direct Care
Facilities New Hampshire hospital Glenco
Glencliff home Hampstead Hospital and
some new Youth Services treatment center
and I'm going to talk a little bit about
Hampstead Hospital in the recent
acquisition later on in the presentation
we protect the health and safety of our
citizens
um the the first bullet there protect
children and adults from abuse and
neglect DC White you know when you think
of that I think of division of children
youth and families division of long-term
supports and services uh we provide it
we assist with providing housing
supports for those who are at risk of
becoming homeless or are homeless as
well
and then finally down down at the bottom
um one thing that that we also provide
is regulatory oversight for licensing of
Health Care Facilities Child Care
Facilities Food Service businesses as
well so moving on to slide number five
this is a very high level overview of
some of the caseloads
um and and the historical caseloads that
we have seen in recent Years you'll
probably notice two major Trends on the
right with with TANF and a to the
permanently and totally disabled as well
as snap you'll know you'll notice a
subtle decrease here what we're seeing
there is typically as the economy does
better we do see decreases in those
caseload numbers so if if we are
potentially predicting some type of
recession we may anticipate some of
those uh some of those to start to
increase in subsequent years following
any sort of major change in the economic
status
and on the left side there you will also
notice beginning in 2020 particularly in
the Medicaid realm you will see an
increase and please note this is as of
September 1 this data here there'll be
another slide with more up-to-date data
but what you will see there is you will
see that uptick and I'm going to talk a
little bit later about continuous
enrollment under the public health
emergency and Medicaid unwind and and
during that time frame we have been
required to keep individuals on the
Medicaid rolls in order to continue to
receive an additional 6.2 Federal match
and I'm going to talk a little bit about
that later on
so moving quickly on to slide six
um so DHHS if you look at the current
operating budget depending on how you
want to split the numbers we are roughly
45 of the total operating budget we're
55 of federal General and other funds
and we're about 66 percent of uh federal
funds for the entire state budget so I
just want to take a minute to go over
the overall organization of the
department
at the top you have commissioner
shibanet
um and then on moving over to the left
side you have the Deputy Commissioner
overseeing Information Services our
human resources facilities the division
of program quality Integrity as well as
the employee assistance program which
actually provides services to many other
state agencies not just within the
Department of Health and Human Services
and we actually allocate costs to some
of those other agencies you will see
that in our budget
shifting to the right side we have three
associate Commissioners Ann Landry
Marissa hen and Chris santinello and
Inland Rishi oversees the division of
Public Health Services as well as the
division of Medicaid services and the
office of Health Equity uh Marissa hen
oversees a vision for children youth and
families division for Behavioral Health
and Hampstead Hospital
and finally Chris sent now she oversees
the division of Economic and housing
supports and the division of long-term
supports and services if you shift down
towards the bottom you'll see our chief
medical officer Dr Jonathan Ballard our
CEO of New Hampshire hospital is Ellen
Lapointe and she has oversight over at
Glen Cliff home you'll see Chief
Financial Officer myself overseeing the
division of finance and procurement and
then finally our chief legal officer
Melissa sancer overseeing Regulatory and
Licensing services
so moving on to page seven we'll we'll
move into the Staffing conversation here
um I think there's a couple of things
that will probably immediately jump out
um our division of Medicaid services uh
if you if you take a look at that
there's there's 31 positions there not
all of those are full currently
um that team oversees approximately 1.2
billion dollars which is a pretty
significant chunk of our budget uh the
division for children Youth and Family
excuse me dividend for children youth
and families has a lot of Direct Care uh
individuals whether it's at City new
Youth Services Center Juvenile Justice
or Child Protective Service workers a
lot of those individuals are out in the
field on a regular basis
we also have New Hampshire hospital
Glenn clip foam in Hampstead are also 24
7 facilities so you'll see New Hampshire
hospital has almost 700 authorized
positions
now in contradistinction to that you'll
see Hampstead Hospital Residential
Treatment Facility only has 21. some of
you may be aware that we've chosen a
different operating model for that
particular facility and that will impact
one of our prioritized needs that you'll
see in our request and what we've done
there in at New Hampshire hospital the
nurses the mental health the social
workers all of those individuals are
classified state employees we've taken a
different approach with Hampstead
Hospital where we have six members that
are unclassified that are executive
senior executive level overseeing that
facility as well as about 15 classified
staff that are looking at they they deal
with more of the facilities the accounts
payable accounts receivable whereas all
the direct care of the mental health
workers social workers nurses those are
clinicians those are all handled by a
private contractor currently
if you move on to page eight um we're
going to look at some of the historical
Staffing
um and and this does feed into some of
our prioritized needs requests and and
that's why I'm talking to you about it
today so I think the most striking thing
here is if you look at 2019 we had a
12.4 vacancy rate if you look at today's
rate we're we're right around 21
vacancy and there's obviously been a
number of factors uh March of 2020 code
19 pandemic hit we saw a number of folks
leave at the outset of that we were also
put under as was All State agencies at
that time an executive order as a hiring
freeze now concurrently we also had a 30
million dollar back of the budget cut in
20 20 21 and then we had a 22.6 million
dollar back of the budget cut for the
current biennium the difference being in
this biennium it was a personnel only
related back of the budget cut so one of
the first things that I did when I took
over this past spring was sent out a
listing to every division director
saying you need to hold X number of
positions vacant and what's that what
that has done on in order to hit that is
it's really limited our ability to
actually post many of our positions
which you know just continues to kind of
feed into that vacancy rate that we
experience we do have some prioritized
needs requests that I'm not going to go
into too much detail today on uh for
uh New Hampshire hospital to continue
enhancements that are current that were
relatively recently approved by GNC to
make those those particular positions
competitive with the private Market
you've probably already heard and I know
this has been a general theme of some of
these hearings some of the challenges
that we have had in our hiring and we
are certainly no exception and it varies
from from area to facility so our nurses
we have a much harder time I think it's
roughly 40 some odd percent vacancy rate
at New Hampshire hospital now if you
contrast that against the private
the private organization that we work
with at Hampstead I think they're at
about 80 some odd percent filled
positions for their nurses so they have
a little bit more flexibility in order
to hire that we do not currently have we
also do have a prioritized need for New
Hampshire hospital asking for additional
funding to utilize the statute that was
relatively recently approved for New
Hampshire hospital glencliffe and other
Direct Care positions in order to
provide Recruitment and Retention
bonuses
now one other really important thing to
understand about some of the challenges
that we do have and how that feeds into
our overall budget is when we are short
staffed or we do have a significant High
number of vacancies or we are required
to hold those positions vacant we do put
federal funds at risk either through
audit findings or paybacks or other
potential negative consequences as well
as Service delivery so well we may save
a certain amount of dollars by holding
positions vacant we do in the long run
create some potential risks that may be
acceptable but certainly need to be
acknowledged
if you move to the next page uh page
nine this is the efficiency budget
request is the high level and this
includes all funds
um I think the the division of Medicaid
services certainly jumps out at you um
this is certainly one of our one of our
higher uh cost areas um but again this
is the the Managed Care organizations
and the the contract is north of 1.2
billion dollars
um the another large areas uh division
of long-term supports and services
um this is what you'll see in those
class lines are the dollars for DD
nursing home amquip Pro share uh we have
one accounting unit alone that's 300
million over 300 million dollars in that
area
um you'll see the prioritizing these
requests at approximately 3.5 billion
dollars in 24 and 3.6 billion dollars in
state fiscal year 25. our prioritized
need we do expect to be able to get that
down when we submitted our agency
request when we were working on this
about four or five months ago we had to
make certain assumptions about what we
anticipated the various needs in in the
community to be we have since worked
with those and we hope to continue to
work with James in the governor's office
as we go forward to get those figures
down and so I think if you move to the
next page on page 10 that general fund
what you're looking at here is total
General funds only
and there are in in our prioritized need
I I just want to recognize that we do
have about total roughly 20 million
dollars of legislative initiatives that
were passed related to Medicaid and
ambulatory rates
um and birthing center rates and in and
out Services
as well as from Seinfeld 444 about a
million dollars for Family Resource
Centers as well those are reflected
currently in in the prioritized needs
column there were a few other things our
our mmis operating budget was placed
into hb2 from this prior session that's
roughly 10 million dollars General funds
11 and 24 or 11 million dollars in
fiscal year 25 uh 41 million roughly
total we are hoping to get that back
into our efficiency budget and get that
out of hp2 but that is also reflected in
that prioritized need line in front of
you
so I will let's be before we get into
prioritize need on page 11 of the
document in front of you we do have a
slide here and it's this function
Centric circle slide to try to outline
some of the complexity of dhhs's budget
um I I do wish at times it was a little
bit more simple but uh For Better or For
Worse it is not but it is explainable
um so on the right I I'd like to start
with the cost allocation so we usually
we utilize a cost allocation system at
DHHS and what that allows us to do is it
allows us to better leverage federal
dollars
um and for example we have we have
executive level leadership positions
today that are paid with over 250
various Federal sources of funding
um and and that that certainly adds a
layer of complexity to our budget on the
left there we have our budget we make
certain Revenue estimates we make
certain predictions for what the needs
are in the bottom we have our actual
experience we of course need to balance
that against the laps HHS is typically
looked at for the largest portion of the
lapse as my prior comments about the
size of our budget
um as I mentioned earlier that certainly
makes sense and that's something that we
are constantly constantly keeping an eye
on as well as managing those those back
of the budget cuts I think one
complexity that we have that many other
state agencies may not necessarily have
is our Direct Care organizations they
actually receive patient revenue and in
order to receive patient Revenue we need
to be able to have patients come in in
order to receive individuals coming in
we need to have staff and if we have
Staffing challenges
and we're not able to compensate them
enough then we lose out on that revenue
and so it's it's this kind of
interesting Catch-22 relationship there
between having adequate staff and having
additional revenues which would offset
general fund expenditures in those
particular areas so um long story short
the key takeaway from this slide is as
we move into the um the upcoming budget
discussions
um just pointing out the complexity of
our budget
on page 12 so let's talk a little bit
about our prioritized needs and honestly
I'm going to cover over 100 million
dollars of prioritizing these in the
next couple of slides but giving them
time
um that's what we'll do so Medicaid
continuous enrollment so
we have been uh the public health
emergency has been in place since 2020
and DHHS has earned an additional 6.2
Federal Medicaid assistance percentage
now this has been conditioned on on
continuous enrollment of Medicaid
beneficiaries and yet we have not known
when the public health emergency is
going to end I think this has been a big
question you've probably seen this in
the news and it's come up many times now
we've continued to work on making
redeterminations every 12 months for our
for the for the beneficiaries that we do
have but at the bottom there you will
see some of the enrollment Trends prior
back in February 2019 through October of
this year overall we've seen a 36
percent increase because those those are
all the individuals that have come on
Medicaid that we have not been able to
disenroll in order to continue to
receive that 6.22 as of September last
time I ran the numbers we had received
about 33
332 million dollars of um of additional
fmap through Medicaid continuous
enrollment uh now the grand Advantage
expansion group this is obviously the
highest increase that you see there
we've seen over a roughly 79 increasing
growth on
page 13
so there's a couple of little not quite
boxes but I'll call them boxes so
currently as of today the public health
emergency is scheduled to end April 11th
if that happens and and that's kind of a
big if
if that happens we can begin the unwind
process on May 1st we would continue to
receive the 6.2 fmap
through June 30th of 2023. we do expect
to receive and and this has been stated
publicly by the federal government many
times that we will receive 60 AIDS
notice so that puts us right around the
beginning of February
now if this happens the fmap will return
to 50 50 for standard Medicaid it will
return to 65 percent for chip expansion
I think just one important note
expansion is already at the max fmap
possible it's already at 90 10 so
there's there'll be no change there that
will just continue as as is
now we have been working actively on
continuing to make sure that we uh we we
conduct we determined redeterminations
on individuals that are currently
enrolled and
um once once the disenrollment process
begins I think it's really important to
note that all of these individuals have
the opportunity to appeal
in a typical year we deal with about a
thousand appeals we don't know how many
individuals will appeal I think that's
that's kind of an X Factor and that will
be hard for us to predict but if an
individual does appeal that would mean
that they would continue to receive
Medicaid benefits and that's kind of the
big X Factor and the unknown
um that that we don't yet necessarily
have an answer before I think that's
going to be difficult to predict
on page 14 I get into a couple of the
prioritized needs that are directly
related to this you will see in our
agency budget requests we put in uh
collectively a 28 million 28 million
dollars
um now for the individuals who would
continue to be on the program who may
not be eligible
now that was worst case scenario and we
do hope to and and we hope to get words
sooner than later as to when the public
health emergency will land that was
assuming it would end in October uh we
hope it will will end earlier than that
I can't make any promises though but
that would cover essentially that that
shortfall that we would experience in in
losing the 6.2 F map we also have a
prioritized need for a call center to
support the eligibility redetermination
work we do expect
as the disenrollment process
starts to have many many questions come
in and it's a tier we would plan for
tier one call center they wouldn't be
conducting eligibility but they would be
the individuals that would help steer
those individuals towards the correct
um
individual to use that word again
um one one other element here that is
not necessarily reflected in a
prioritized need as of today is we
expect the individuals that would be
disenrolled from Medicaid to likely be
to be lower Acuity so in the long run as
this process unfolds the individuals
that would continue to be on Medicaid
would likely be of a higher Acuity
Acuity nature and that would cause the
actuarially determined rates to
potentially increase which could have an
impact so while we would see you know
the actual numbers go down we may
potentially see an increase in the per
member per month cost that we would
experience we if the if if the PHD does
end in May or excuse me April and the
disenrollment begins in may we would
likely stagger based on some of the CMS
guidance that has been provided of
disenrolling one-ninth of the of the
potential population each each month we
would Target those that we think would
be the least likely to appeal those that
were were fairly certain would not
continue to qualify for Medicaid first
and that would also set us up for
success in subsequent years so that
um we wouldn't attempt to disenroll a
number of people and then have a number
of appeals and then next year everybody
all the redeterminations would be
required at the same time during the
following year
so moving on to page 15
um so starting with Hampstead Hospital
Residential Treatment Center so the
state and I don't know if this is the
first time in New Hampshire history but
uh first time in recent memory we
acquired a Hampstead Hospital
and that that acquisition became
effective June 8th of 2022. we Hampstead
Hospital primarily serves Youth and
Young adults with acute psychiatric
needs we are in the process of
attempting to open up a psychiatric
Residential Treatment Facility as well
in calendar year 23.
the the operating budget
um that was approved by the fiscal
committee uh this um included
approximately nine million dollars of
arpathons um we have requested an
equivalent amount of General funds for
the upcoming biennium in the first year
uh to cover to cover the costs of the
existing contract
um One Challenge here is we don't have a
history on what the patient revenues
will be we really only have a several
you know since June we really only have
several months of actual actual Revenue
so I think it's difficult to predict
long term historically what we expect
those to be based on some of the
information that we've seen coming out
we do potentially expect the second year
in state fiscal year 25 where we would
be going back out compared to
competitively bid that contract we do
expect some of those contracted costs to
increase I think the report released by
The New Hampshire hospital association's
quoted something like 116 percent
increase has been experienced in
contracted Staffing costs at hospitals
so
um we that's that's the reason why you
do see that year over year um that
significant increase there
the forensic facility
um as as you know uh during this past uh
each this current or this prior HB to
approximately 30 million dollars was
appropriated to the department to build
the forensic facility roughly eight
million dollar 8.75 million dollars a
year prior was appropriated in hb2 and
you recently did see the department come
forward to the fiscal committee to
transfer some funds in order to address
some of the increased construction costs
that we have been experiencing due to
rampant inflation
um and and the labor market currently we
are scheduled to open in state fiscal
year 25 we do have a prioritized need in
24 and 25 they're it's 100 General funds
we researched we looked we could not
find any potential Federal source that
we could utilize for this particular
facility at this time it's 19 million
dollars in general funds the first year
24 million dollars in general funds
second year you're probably thinking
well why do you need funding the first
year prior to it opening our intent and
our goal was to bring in staff have them
trained and ready to go on day one
there's also dollars included in that
first year request in order to hire an
external consultant to conduct a
national search to try to bring in staff
to address some of the challenges that
we we obviously collectively are
experiencing relative to the labor
market
um the next item there it is not a
traditional prioritized need it is not
in our prioritized need column uh so New
Year's Services Center their their
budget today is currently included in
hb2
um it is not found in hb1
um we we have requested through through
the hb2 process approximately 11.11.4
million dollars of General funds
um under the assumption that there will
be uh fast-tracked legislation to
postpone the current schedule close of
March of 20 2023 of the facility there
was legislation that that was not
successful this past session
um to continue that um and and I know
that our team has been working closely
with some members of the legislature in
an attempt to Fast Track legislation to
ensure that we do have funding for the
remainder of State fiscal year 23.
and we work has begun to design a
replacement facility for the senior use
Services Center as of today
on the next page
um the next kind of major theme Here is
rates
the the the first area is developmental
disabilities we have been working on um
the the term the new acronym is is the
dads rate the designated area agency
delivery services Daz is certainly a
little bit easier and this is to provide
Direct Care Services historically the
methodology that has been used
um for for for the payment model the
area agency's CMS has found that to be
non-compliant and we have been working
over more than a year and a half now
maybe close to two years I believe
um we have been working internally with
a team and an external consultant to
bring that model into compliance as a
result of doing so we do initially
expect approximately 16.2 and 27 million
dollar of general fund need in those two
years however that figure is still the
moving as this work is still in
development the team just as a side note
has done a phenomenal job they've been
out in the community I think they've met
with over 50 different they've held over
50 different sessions with
community-based providers other
interested parties and and families that
that are potentially affected by this
the next prioritized need is the choices
for Independence this this prioritized
need is based on our current projections
I think one important thing to remember
here is choices for Independence it
allows individuals to receive the
services in their homes
and nursing home services are an
entitlement whereas this is part of a
waiver program I think that's just
really a key distinction so it's kind of
one of those areas where do you spend
the money and potentially save money in
in the long run and and you know I think
that obviously when we're talking 19
million dollars that is certainly a
tricky calculation to make but I do just
want to recognize if individuals aren't
receiving Services here the alternative
is likely a nursing facility
um we did include a 10 million dollar
prioritized need for Medicaid to address
ongoing required CMS rate increases as
well
on page 17
last year with children residential
rates last year we entered into a new
Contracting model with a residential
treatment facilities
and we took our best educated guess at
what those rates should be we have since
looked at those and we are requesting
additional funding in order to modify
those this is another rate that we
continue to Monitor and we hope as we
get closer to the to the the the budget
rollout that we can work with work with
the governor's office or the House and
Senate
um to to better refine those once we
have more accurate data again this is
another one of those moving I don't want
to call it a moving Target but but it's
it's one of those things four months ago
is obviously not today and we have
better information today than we did
then
we have also included
um in each state fiscal year 10 million
dollars of General funds to support
shelter Services the shelter providers
today uh they they incur about 41
um per person per day in operating costs
the state
um we pay about eight dollars and 46
cents per person per day this request
would get us about up to twenty dollars
give or take to support those those
shelter services to address many of the
ongoing challenges and I think everybody
here has probably seen some of the
potential risks there and and current
homeless situation across the state and
this is really intended to address that
the foster care rate request uh this is
3.25 million dollars total over the
whole biennium currently the rates that
we pay are tied to the low income medium
or low household medium income come this
would increase that to the median
household income and we the the intent
there is to incentivize additional
individuals and families to participate
in the Foster Care Program
shifting onto page 18 this particular
page does not include a prioritized need
it does include in the table there
you'll see safe field Skipper 24 and 25
11.9 11.6 million dollars of prioritized
needs for our I.T systems DHHS as I
mentioned before we are large we have
many different programs many different
divisions and of course supporting all
those are over 139 applications some of
the major systems are listed there on
the left side are mmis system our new
heights eligibility enrollment system
historically the next item Bridges has
has there has been bridges for dcyf
we've been in the process of migrating
this to a new system granted families
and we do have an 11 million dollar
Capital request to support that
particular initiative
um I think it's just important just to
recognize and and I think this has
already been recognized I've listened to
a few of the budget hearings
um that Automation in the long run um
while it may have some initial upfront
costs it may have ongoing costs it can
increase
um efficiencies across the department as
well in order to provide
um the services that the department is
required to provide
on the next page on page 19
um I've only I've pulled out a couple of
our I.T related prioritized need I
believe we have about 16.
um Salesforce this is a this is a system
that is used across the department uh
collectively we have a little a little
over four million dollars of a
prioritized need over the entire
biennium and and this is a platform that
is used in a variety of ways can be
customized we use a currently uh for The
Incident Management for New Hampshire
hospital we do it we do intend to expand
that out to some some of our other
facilities and areas as well
um once once the work at New Hampshire
hospital is done in the system is ready
to to be migrated and expanded
um we this is also used for child care
licensing and training contact training
and case investigation the next item is
consulting services so as I mentioned
earlier
um or many times now we do have
challenges with with hiring and in our
Information Services area last I checked
I think we were roughly 30 32 percent uh
vacancy rate just because it is is
difficult and challenging to hire this
would allow us funding in order to hire
Consulting Services as we need them in
order to augment existing systems or
build existing system or build new
systems or leveraging Salesforce in
order to create new efficiencies for the
department and then lastly we have a
request for ebi software this is roughly
a million dollars over the entire
biennium this this software I think this
is a good example this supports the
automated data and privacy reporting and
compliance requirements prior to prior
to
um
prior to this uh this particular
software a lot of this was highly manual
and time and staff intensive which took
staff away from other priorities and
duties so
that is
um that is all that I have today I
obviously covered a lot in a very short
amount of time but I will weren't happy
to take any questions
okay thank you and thank you for your
for your testimony
um to the extent that a budget is a
financial prioritization of needs
um you
your your department does quite a bit I
mean it poverty homelessness mental
health Child Care Child Abuse Public
Health which includes drug and alcohol
abuse to name a few
uh and and while I imagine this list of
priorities would have changed I mean
maybe a year and a half ago if I
mentioned it would have clearly been
public health because the covet epidemic
maybe
um but what currently what are your
priorities for what you do
foreign
I think right now our most pressing
needs is to maintain operations as they
are today you know if I had to you can't
prioritize one vulnerable population
over the other like you said
um every year there's a different area
that is in crisis Public Health was in
crisis during covid but you know
fortunately for states most of the
coveted response was federally funded
both through Public Health dollars
through our cares act all of those
things we've been in an ongoing Mental
Health crisis for about a decade now we
have a 10-year Mental Health Plan there
was dcyf Crisis a couple of years ago so
it's not that you can pick one area or
one vulnerable population over another
but maintaining operations as they are
today is our priority and then our
prioritized needs going forward
traditionally is the either the
expansion of those programs to the the
transformation of some of those programs
but I think in what's different about
this budget is some of our basic
operations to maintain programs are in
prioritized needs this biennium so our
prioritized needs a lot of those dollars
actually should be in our efficiency
budget you think of things like
Hampstead Hospital if we don't get that
prioritized needs request we are going
to have to reduce beds so so it is
really about maintaining where we are
today and then our prioritized needs
should be about what's the next step in
Transforming Our systems both our
systems of care and our I.T systems to
help us better serve the people of New
Hampshire thank you measure
the now you you mentioned that the
vacancy rate which I believe was just
over 20 percent
um
how quickly do you believe you're going
to be able to fill those positions
assuming they're they're fully funded
meaning have you here
you seen any increase in
uh applications and people coming into
the state government who want to work
for you so the the 21 is an aggregate uh
so a car solid Department I think is
Nathan alluded to earlier for Hampstead
we have seen that uptick we've seen
nurses go up to say an 82 percent vacant
filled rate whereas at New Hampshire
hospital not so much and we have
different infrastructure and operating
systems for sure so some of it is going
to be how much we can rely on other help
I.E a different model to do that
recruitment for us that doesn't
necessarily have some of the same
constraints that the state system does
that said we've made great strides I
think with the division of personnel and
the money that they've gotten through
our dollars to help with our recruiting
retention so we are seeing an uptick but
the challenges that as soon as you gain
you lose right so there's constant
attrition so it's really trying to get
get ahead of that
um and as much as a recession isn't a
good thing potentially it does bring
more people in the door to do some of
the work so you know it's it's really
hard with the crystal ball to figure out
the magic formula but I think we have
tools now that we didn't have before so
we're making some smaller steps in in
towards gains okay
um that's something I wanted to touch on
in that the the state has enacted and
you've enacted a recruitment and
retention program for for nursing
in in various areas and I wonder if you
could just briefly touch on whether that
program so far has been successful and
what you're going to need in the future
not only once this current crisis ends
if it is a current crisis and not an
ongoing one but what we're going to what
sort of resource you would need to
attract nurses meaning that uh
they're they're you have two
competitions one you're competing with
private sector and then you're competing
with the overall Nationwide shortage of
nurses
right so and I think those are real-time
challenges I mean the bottom line is
money right so we really can't we can
only compete to a certain extent all
right we can't pay what the hospitals
are paying we can't do the bonuses like
they're doing they they do we do a bonus
they do two bonuses right they may have
a better benefits package what we have
is the draw to people to do the work for
the department and that you wanted to
hear because of the mission-driven work
that we do so we do have that and it
does does factor into it but we will
always be behind those
um professions until something shifts in
the bigger market and once that shifts I
think we'll we'll see a difference but
you know to get to to an 82 fill at
Hampstead that may change in two weeks
right so it you know it's hard to get
the stability with that right now okay
and and you you will see
um in in our prioritized needs request
you as I mentioned earlier
um the Recruitment and Retention
um
RSA that that was amended to provide New
Hampshire hospital with the ability to
to utilize
um you know bonuses and whatnot you will
see roughly three mil a little over
three million dollars of a prioritized
need request in order to to try to
Target
um new new nurses and and other uh
individuals to to come to work for New
Hampshire hospital okay uh my last
question is going to be on on Medicaid
and from from General funds I believe
I'm looking at correctly only it it goes
from roughly 297 million and 23 up to
346 million in fiscal year 25
and uh if I understand it correctly that
we will continue to get the the 6.22
until June 30th of 23 June 30th of 23rd
of 23 but then we just have to you know
that the people who are currently on the
rolls who at that point will be allowed
to be disenrolled
uh how much of these numbers reflect
the disenrollment is that included here
have you included any disenrollment or
what percentage of the people you think
could be disenrolled or showed up in
these numbers right so the um the
figures for that are included um there's
two prioritized needs one is for chip
and one is for standard Medicaid
um chip is uh roughly three million
dollars standard Medicaid is 25 million
dollars it assumes the public health
emergency ends in October and that would
cover the the any of the costs over
um over our other projections so
um I I would expect if if we do get
indications that the public health
emergency will end in April
um then I think I think it would be
appropriate to potentially take a look
at what those prioritizing needs are and
reduce those down
um and and that would be sufficient to
cover essentially those individuals that
continue to be enrolled that shouldn't
necessarily be enrolled
um however the the The X Factor in all
that is the appeals we don't know how
many we're going to get but we do expect
uh the entire process to probably take
about nine months and there has been a
team working on on that distance just so
you you both are everyone is aware there
has been a team working on that process
for about over two years they meet every
Friday there's a whole Collective crew
of individuals involved in that so the
moment we get noticed we are ready to go
because again each month that we keep
individuals on
um on the on the role or you know that
that we will incur our costs for that we
will no longer be compensated for that
through that 6.2 percent fmap okay and
when do we find out if the Federal
Emergency is going to end in April uh at
least 60 days in advance so I guess that
would put us somewhere around February
11th or so maybe February 10th so about
four days before the budget is due
perfect timing right
excellent thank you sure
um good morning
um as a follow-up to what James had
asked if
those going through the appeal process
are found
um that the appeal is
um the disenrollment was correct I'll
say it that way
um as you drew the Medicaid during that
period of time is there an opportunity
to recoup
that Medicaid at all you know what
happens during that sort of appeal
process period
so at any individual that is is enrolled
during that time frame the the state
would be liable for right yeah okay
um and then I'm going to shift gears
just a little bit on the redesign model
for
um the dads 50 dads um
does that model include and I'm not sure
where you send with this fully funding
um all of the clients you have a wait
list at all
um in any of those areas so so our
prioritized needs requests and includes
fully funding okay that that area yes
based on current projection are based on
projections as of four months ago
um and and I believe we have provided
additional information since then
um about potentially decreasing that
those figures
um as well and we're going to conduct
another analysis here soon uh to come up
with with the most accurate data
possible the last
um when when I looked at this back after
the budget was submitted this is the end
of September
um we would currently based on updated
information be able to reduce the
prioritizing requests by about 26
million dollars John
um 50 50 Federal General funds in 24 and
42 million dollars 50 50 Federal General
funds in 25. okay and so those dollars
are the fully fund is that separate than
the that is separate okay the 16 it's
numbers are close but the 16 million and
the 27 million on page 16 at handout
that talked about the payment model
that's independent of the correct okay
yes okay thank you
that's all I have
thank you very much but before you go
this seems to be a day of goodbye so I
just would like to uh to add my um the
sentiments on on you commissioner uh you
you are the commissioner of the largest
and most certainly complicated budget
for sure uh but it's a state agency as I
said that does so many things that have
major consequences in people's lives and
if that wasn't enough within weeks of
you taking this job covet hit and I
think the the New Hampshire's excellent
record in covid in which apparently
everyone has an opinion on and certainly
gave it to you I'm sure
um that the record speaks for itself and
there was no better person for the job
than you and you will be greatly missed
thank you
foreign
of Labor up for their testimony
yeah good morning
foreign
again Absolutely I'll clean it again
good morning and uh for the record I am
Ken Merrifield the commissioner of the
Department of Labor and joined by Deputy
Commissioner Rudy Ogden uh the
department consists of three divisions
Administration which includes
department-wide activities like human
resources finance and I.T the Inspection
Division which is tasked with the
enforcement of States employment safety
rather famously elevator and pressure
vessel statutes
and the largest division is the worker
Compensation Division which is tasked
with monitoring the state's work of
compensation system and providing a
platform for the resolution of disputes
uh in each of the last three fiscal
years the Inspection Division has
recovered in excess of a million dollars
in wages for New Hampshire employees
completed uh typically about 500 labor
inspections completed roughly 10 000
boiler and pressure vessel inspections
and over 5 000 elevator inspections the
division is also proactive training
employers every year on employment law
to assist them in in compliance matters
as a consequence of the Public Health
crisis that we've all endured in 2020
we've also developed
virtual training for employers and plan
to continue that offering that service
into the future
the Workers Compensation Division
collects first reports of the injury
from employers and insurance carriers on
the roughly 40
000 workplace injuries that occur each
year
um it also schedules uh roughly 1500
formal hearings per year due to uh
disputes in worker compensation cases
and also manages uh unappropriated
unbudgeted trust fund Collections and
payments of nearly 20 million dollars a
year which if you look at our operating
budget uh is about double the size of
the department as a whole
um
while the Department's total
Appropriations are funded a hundred
percent by agency income uh that revenue
is derived through two distinct sources
the administration fund and the
restricted fund the administration fund
is described in RSA 281a 59 and comes
from a pro rata assessment of the
Department's annual budget for worker
compensation activities levied on the
worker compensation insurance carriers
and self-insured entities in New
Hampshire you'll note that about 88
percent of our budget request for 2024
for fiscal 2024 is represented by that
Administration fund the restricted fund
however is described in RSA 2731b and it
comes from the the sum of all other fees
licenses certificates and civil
penalties that the department of lab
manages the balance of the restricted
fund following our expenses the balance
of that fund is transferred to the
general fund at the conclusion of each
fiscal year
the department has reported record
revenues to the general fund in each of
the last two years exceeding two million
dollars in fiscal 21 and 3 million
dollars in fiscal 22.
um uh and I would say that you know that
there are two sides to that coin yes uh
record revenues but also uh
exceptionally good uh expense control
has led to those um record transfers
uh my understanding is that self-funded
agencies were not required to hit the
governor's requested expenditure targets
however the labor department has done so
in 24 and 25 uh the the governor uh
provided an overall efficiency Target of
uh just over 11 million dollars in year
one for the labor department
representing a three percent uh increase
from uh 23 adjusted authorized the
adjusted year two target was uh slightly
higher about three hundred thousand
dollars higher after allowances for
currently filled positions
um again we met both of those targets
with our efficiency budget request
and while we've requested no new
positions for 24 25 despite the
abolition of Aid in the current biennium
the governor's targets did allow us to
refund all remaining uh full-time
positions in the department so we are
requesting full funding for all of our
all of our department full-time
positions
other operational changes that we're
requesting in our agency budget include
the addition of a class 103 for
operational contracts we envision this
being used for certain Building
Maintenance and Repair needs
um for a total of 75 000 over the course
of the biennium we're also requesting a
new board expenses class 65 as a
companion to House Bill 2 language that
we're requesting that would allow us to
pay per DM members of a very important
administratively attached board that has
presented some recruiting and retention
problems for us at the department
we also moved our indirect cost payments
line into the administration Division
and we boosted the amount of money
available for employee training due to
concerns that we've had about
rapid staff turnover we feel that we we
need to uh
increase the speed with which our new
hires are able to be helpful to us we've
had been a very stable Department
um uh with our staff for many many years
but in recent years that has changed
dramatically and like a lot of other
agencies we've lost a lot of a lot of
folks so we need to bring them up to
speed faster
we do have prioritized needs that are
being requested Priority One is about
thirty six thousand dollars and is
related to administrative Services
um and related to retiree Health uh
priority two is about a hundred thousand
dollar request also from administrative
Services relative to certain building
needs at the Labor Department
headquarters the Spalding building
and priority three is funding in both
years of the biennium for uh roughly 130
000 from the Department of Information
Technology uh due to certain allocated
uh or direct expenses largely associated
with technology improvements that we're
making at the department
and that concludes my remarks and we're
happy to answer any questions you might
have great thank you how many employees
do you currently have we have the 86
full-time positions and
trying to remember I just ran a query
yesterday on the number of build I think
it is roughly 70.
have these been long standing open
positions
uh those that were longest standing were
abolished in the in the current so that
was the a positions that were abolished
um uh I would say that the rest of those
are more frequent fills more recent
fills
okay
yeah I think I'm good
um can you just talk a little bit again
I missed your the 50 000 which was the
new contract line did you say that was
building related
yeah well I'll give you I'll give you a
perfect example that we're experiencing
right now the
um the security surveillance
surveillance video system that we have
in the department is really aged and not
operating
uh uh so we have no video surveillance
of the building we want to replace that
and and the only place that I can go to
I have no contract lines the only place
that I can go to is equipment or current
expense it seems appropriate for us to
have some kind of uh funding for and and
we have the space within Target to
create a contract line
so that I was just trying to understand
sort of the difference of what that need
would be outside of the general Services
sure
um budget that provides
um some building
really for you okay thank you sure
okay actually I did have one one more
question it's actually a line Automotive
to try not to get into this level of
detail here but I'm going to here
um I believe it is the the pension
benefit health insurance
line and it and it goes from 260
000 roughly to uh in fiscal year 22 uh
and it jumped up to 336
000 in 23. and can you tell me which
Which accounting unit in class yeah this
is this is on page three this is the
overall oh in the budget book yeah and
it's major operating expenses and it's
fourth one from the bottom
and I think that's um what you pay to
admin services in class 64.
okay yeah so so these are figures that
are provided to us by admin Services
um excuse me
why did they go up so much
do you know the specifics
um I know that and
some agencies are charged let me back up
a little bit
um the state pays for retiree health
insurance agencies that have
traditionally been you know
self-self-funded type agencies get
charged their share of what that retiree
health insurance is going to be so those
numbers are estimated by the Bureau of
risk and benefits based on
um a percentage of of employees
I wonder to
um commissioner Rockburn
could could experience in Prior years
have an impact on that as well because
we did have a large number of
retirements
um yeah okay I think that's the answer
right there
okay thank you very much for your
testimony sure
also well great thank you
I'd like to invite the Department of
Business and economic affairs
foreign
I just happened to flip the book open
and it went right to your page
I'm not sure if that's good or bad but
that was that was amazing if I'm seeing
you it must be Thursday
good morning
a quick overview
excuse me commissioner if you could just
turn your microphone on here we go is it
on now oh much better thank you
um uh as you know ba was established in
2017 uh since we were last here for a a
budget biennial uh process a lot has
changed at the department we have a
distinctly different feel here as a
result of covet and the programs that
we've been involved in in helping the
state recover from the economic impacts
of the pandemic and we continue to do
that kind of work and I think some of
the changes and some of the
responsibilities that you receive
reflected in this budget are really as a
result of a lot of those initiatives and
strategies so I mean with the specific
areas that we are seeing this is in some
new changes in the way that we operate
with our rapid response program and the
office of Workforce opportunity working
with businesses that are are having an
unfortunately difficult time weathering
the pandemic and the impacts of that and
changing the way that we operate that
from a very sort of siled situation and
process that was in place previously to
a much more integrated process that
involves other agencies but also
involves other divisions within our
department which is creating a good deal
of value add in those unfortunate
situations and retaining Workforce in
the state
as we as we see these changes in
different air in different industries of
course we have the office and Broadband
initiatives which was initiated with
arpa funds and the and the invest New
Hampshire housing program there's just
as an aside in those two programs we
have a total of six 90 positions that
are operating those two programs but as
you know sort of in the small agency
world that we live within there is a a
lot of integrated
work that gets done on a policy level
between our existing Bea staff and those
federally funded operations so while
we're not talking about arpa obviously
here today but those are impacts that
um we just you know integrate into our
overall operation
um as far as organization we're
currently at 7 600 positions uh 72
classified foreign classified seven on
seven on only seven unfilled vacant
positions this does not include the bvs
numbers our Bureau of visitor Services
we do have
um some part-time positions that exist
under that
umbrella with the rest areas in the
welcome welcome centers
so that puts our vacancy rate right now
just under 10 percent uh with those
seven vacant positions
um
I would note that um uh for the for the
most part those vacant positions are
vacant
um because we are in the process of
reclassifying them uh those are
positions that we expect to
um uh get get filled at some point uh in
the in the foreseeable future some with
federal funds uh and otherwise
but just in terms of our organization we
have two primary divisions we have the
division of Economic Development and
within that division we have teams that
work in business Recruitment and
expansion these are the people that work
with businesses that are looking to
relocate to New Hampshire or locate to
New Hampshire or expand in New Hampshire
uh they've been quite busy as you might
imagine over the last couple of years we
have our business support and technical
assistance staff these are organizations
we commonly refer to as our retention
team these are individuals who are
working with businesses that are in New
Hampshire and are looking to grow their
business in one way or another or
looking for assistance with state
government or just working with our
Economic Development partners and
implementation of strategies they're our
primary team as it relates to that we
also have the office of international
Commerce that is responsible for all the
international relations the state has
with our at least from an economic
standpoint with is you know a lot of
Canada but increasingly a lot of
operation and interaction in Europe uh
and in Asia
that that office is not entirely but
primarily funded by a federal SBA grants
uh under the step program
we have our office of Workforce
opportunity which is designated State
entity to administer the federal
Workforce Innovation and Opportunity Act
that we owe programs that it's funds
that we cooperate with at the New
Hampshire employment security and uh and
other outside agencies cap agencies to
provide job training and support
services to adult dislocated adult
workers and also to youth in youth
programming
uh we have our procurement technical
assistance center which is every state
has one of these this is funded by the
Department of Defense uh it's largely an
operation that allows our staff to work
with businesses that are looking to do
subcontracting work with the federal
government usually in a military
standpoint but increasingly in a much
more Broad and a much more broad set of
instances
and then of course we have our within
DED is also the invest in h housing team
and the Broadband team
uh as of this is our first full budget
with the office of Planning and
Development this was the planning
division that was previously at OSI
before that
um iterations of that became part of the
Department of energy
um that staff Works primarily in zoning
and planning with different communities
and uh it is a nice mix and a nice
addition to our department we continue
to work to integrate that team with our
overall operation with our Economic
Development and travel and tourism team
and then of course we have the division
of travel tourism development this is uh
the the tourism division that uh its
primary function is marketing the state
uh as a tourist destination
um we have been
um over the last several years on a a
real mission to see the work that that
operation does integrate much more
closely to our overall strategies of
recruiting not just tourists to New
Hampshire but Workforce but businesses
use students and so on and taking a lot
of the Baseline work that we do for
tourism and Hospitality marketing and
transferring that into a format that we
can use for those other instances as
well and that has shown some good
success in some areas and as a result
the marketing component here you know
continues to be a major function and
priority for the Department
and then lastly I would say lastly one
of these days I'll start with the Bureau
of visitor Services because they are a
big part of our operation
um they are only operational function uh
within ba uh we are under an mou with
the New Hampshire Department of
Transportation to manage the 12 welcome
centers and safety rest areas around the
state
um that has I will be honest been a one
of our more challenging components over
the last year just because when we did
scale back during covid it's been really
hard to get that operation back to where
it was before covid in terms of Staffing
these are not very well paid positions
as a general rule
um before covert we were operating just
within bvs with a staff of around 77
individuals a little bit of about
two-thirds of those were part-time we're
down I think now around 38 or 39 and
employees and the majority of those are
full-time employees as it turns out
right at this point we've been juggling
operations we used to be open seven days
a week 20 you know seven days a week in
every one of the 12 welcome centers
um at this point where we have the main
welcome centers on the border uh those
are open the southern ones are open 24
hours but some of the others are really
difficult to manage because we just
don't have the staff we've explored
because everyone always asks me their
relationship with like local Chambers
and other things to do there but there
are some restrictions to what we can do
with that regard and we haven't had a
lot of success in recruiting a chamber
to help with that Staffing those centers
to this point and that's not for a lack
of trying
I would say lastly just a couple of the
priorities that we have I mentioned the
marketing uh we want to continue to
obviously make that a focus of the work
that we do at the department and
transfer that into all the other forms
that I had mentioned but at the same
time our division of Economic
Development we did develop uh just at
the in early 2021 the state economic
recovery and expansion strategy a lot of
that work in the work of the division of
economic development is now in
implementing that plan and we've had
some very good success in uh seeing some
changes to the way that the state
interacts with its Partners on an
economic development level and uh and
that is a sort of fomenting a good deal
of support for our collaborative
Economic Development regions which are
really an effort to take all of these
things that we do within within Bea
including tourism including helping
potentially maybe with the welcome
centers but also primarily with the
economic development activity is to have
they're a much more Regional focus on
the economic recovery strategies that we
have in place and to be able to
implement those in coordination where we
have not done that before so just as a
quick example we have had uh you know
the sole responsibility for business
recruitment in the state at uh at Bea
and previously at dread with a staff of
two and sometimes three individuals that
can be a a heavy load when you're in a
time like this where you're seeing
continued expansionist activity
um we we have never really had
relationships with local Chambers or
local economic development organizations
or municipalities to assist in the work
of recruiting businesses and that that's
a that's a big lift I mean you've got to
involve Workforce training you got to
have academic institutions you got to
demonstrate long-term commitments and
all these sorts of things uh having a
regional partner with those has been
huge in a real success story for us and
my we're continuing to grow those
relationships and then of course as I
mentioned I keep bringing up the housing
and Broadband because those are two
areas that are just so Central to our
economic future and to have those within
Bea and have those leaching through into
all of our other strategies and the work
that we're doing really increases the
meaning and the value that we're able to
bring to employers around the state
the very last thing and then I'll stop
talking is the uh one of the areas that
we have uh I wouldn't say struggled but
noticed a need an increasing need
particularly with the growth of some of
these types of activities and the
centralization of a lot of
administrative components that have
historically been done by division and
to try to centralize those into one a a
much more efficient way of approaching
those between the federal contracts
between all of the funds and the
Staffing and the increase in and changes
in Staffing that we've been having and
the and and chasing Workforce as
everyone else is is really to provide
some investment in our the
administrative side of Bea when we were
established in 2017 we came over from
dread with basically two individuals who
were tasked with being the business the
entire business office for the
Department we have had some changes in
that over the last five years years
Rhonda Hensley has just joined us that
she's here what three weeks on the job
uh here at ba and so she's going to be
leading that effort but getting a little
bit more investment in that side of the
house I think is going to help
manage a lot of these changes that we
have going on internally so those are
really the updates from my standpoint
we're happy to answer any questions okay
thank you commissioner I just really
have two questions one sort of is a is a
broader question that relates to
revenues actually given the business
profits taxes is such a huge component
of general fund revenues and uh if you
to follow the the economics where you
know we've had record near record
inflation followed by absolute record uh
interest rate Rises that every time this
happened in the past in the United
States we've had a recession to follow
how
uh how well is New Hampshire
uh position to handle say a moderate
recession and if you could maybe just
talk about the basic
uh economy of New Hampshire and how it
may have changed from our last recession
in 2007-2008
uh well there's a lot there so
um I would say first of all in terms of
how we've changed uh New Hampshire is
definitely on a trajectory right now uh
toward a sort of a more high-tech type
of economy we have seen
um that happening in a multitude of ways
you know you look at the energy costs
for example
um the commercial rates of providing
heat or electricity to
highly intense
manufacturing operations say like
Kitchener Manufacturing in Milford where
they melt steel and other you know sort
of Legacy
manufacturing facilities like paper
mills in the North country or in in the
southwest area of the state we've seen
those operations start to scale down
very significantly not all of them I
don't want to put hitchner in that
category because they make me I have
seen a lot of success but a lot of the
heavy industry type of jobs that have
been traditionally the center of our
manufacturing industry have started to
downsize or just go somewhere else and a
lot of that is due to the energy cost
the cost of electricity not something
that is exclusive to New Hampshire it is
something that we see throughout the
Northeast and so while a lot of people
say well that's Doom and Gloom about all
of that what they're being replaced with
are more advanced manufacturers that
have that have probably in a lot of
cases better higher paying positions
higher paying jobs but have energy use
rates that are way that are
significantly less and so they're
finding the workforce that they need
sort of within this Tech base and it
really sort of emanates from
Massachusetts but we're increasingly
part of and so we're we're seeing
expansion activity in areas like life
science in areas like just basic
technology or Advanced manufacturing and
that is a result of the fact that while
there are still higher energy costs that
doesn't impact that industry quite so
much but what they're looking for is a
highly qualified Workforce and we have
that in New Hampshire we have one of the
most highly qualified workforces in the
country we continue to see you know
record low unemployment rates we
continue to hear from businesses of all
type whether they're a restaurant or
whether they're one of these Advanced
manufacturers that they have a need for
staff
um we when we look at all of these
things we don't look at them from the
standpoint as what within the political
borders of New Hampshire and what what
do we have to operate with exclusively
we are all jammed in here together up
here in the Northeast in New England so
we have a lot of people and we lose some
people today to Massachusetts in terms
of employment we also have a large
number of people who come to New
Hampshire and that number is increasing
so
um I would say that's a big change that
we've seen over the last two years it's
been a trend that was before that but
we're continuing to see that grow uh in
terms of how well is New Hampshire
positioned to be able to handle this I
think that the underlying employer-based
private sector uh types of businesses
are larger employers
are in a good position I think we're the
more difficult Industries right now
continue to be Healthcare and
hospitality and those are two obviously
Central components particularly in rural
communities when you look at the impact
of a local small hospital to a town like
Littleton or a town like uh Berlin with
androscogen or even Lebanon and Hanover
area with Dartmouth Hitchcock the
ability to have those high-paying jobs
yes you need health care right you need
to be able to provide those services but
these are some of the highest paying
jobs in those rural communities so
Health Care is critical in Hospitality
of course I mean tourism continues to
remain not just the second largest
industry in our state
it also is I it's the tip of the spear
for everything and you go around and I
talk to groups all the time and you say
how many of you are in Hampshire because
someone in your background in your
family background came here on vacation
and you get two-thirds of the room raise
their hand right so that continues to be
a dynamic that we live and die by so if
we have a tourism industry that is not
supported and is not able to translate
um sort of that weekend experience into
a long-term open a business long-term
you know join a company in New Hampshire
or even work remotely
um uh you know we people who are working
remotely into other areas not just
Boston but San Francisco and New York
our third largest tech employer in New
Hampshire is Facebook we don't have a
Facebook facility anywhere in New
Hampshire but these are people who are
working remotely and they're living in
rural communities and they're you know
participating in their economy there in
a good way and you know tie back to
broadband there right so we need to be
able to have the services available if
I'm an infrastructure standpoint so the
Investments that we've made the
Investments that we've been making in
terms of
in our Economic Development
infrastructure and providing a system
that's much more sustainable to support
businesses as we go forward as is in
place and it's continuing to grow and we
have I think a good sense of where we
want to make those Investments coming
forward but with housing and broadband
and some of these other Investments that
have been made we're in as good of a
position as anyone in competition with
other states
okay thank you and the second time in a
row I'm going to ask for a line item
um see if I can find it here real quick
this one if you have your budget it's on
I'm not sure what page this is on page
five and it's it's a contracted
expenditures
and they go from roughly 3.968 million
in 23 up to 11.5 million in 25 and I
wonder you could explain what that was
okay
the jump was so significant that I had
to
sorry
so I think
um
a good portion of that is some of the
changes that we have made and I'd have
to look at some of the other accounting
units to be sure but we've made some
changes in our office of Workforce
opportunity and the way that that's
funded uh and the way that we interact
with New Hampshire employment security
so there's been some
um uh update in the in in who is
administering those programs so I think
that's the bulk of it I think that uh in
addition
um we have a request under I believe the
division of economic development for
some increase in contractual uh
assistance going forward and that will
be to continue to implement help us
Implement strategies as it relates to
the economic recovery and expansion
strategy so I I don't have the exact
answer as to what that is we can provide
that for you but I do believe that it's
related to our office of Workforce
opportunity changes and then some of the
requests that we've made for the
division of Economic Development great
thank you so much
we just have more of a um it's a general
question um believe it was yesterday the
university system was talking about one
of the programs that they are running
and they're looking to expand is
building Partnerships with students and
private businesses in terms of
internships trying to keep students in
New Hampshire and because you have such
a connection with businesses especially
new ones coming in do they work directly
with your office okay oh yeah yeah I
mean very closely we work with
universities in each of the individual
universities on exactly that subject I
just diploma State yesterday so I refer
to it as the triangle it is definitely
part of our major strategic approach to
grow that qualified Workforce the
triangle being the state our academic
institutions and employers and you know
one of our strategies to really to
normalize that relationship so it's not
just like hey we need a few interns
let's call you know Jim over at UNH and
get a few we want to normalize those
relationships so it's a much better
relay relationship and that we're seeing
some success there yeah one of their um
additional requests was in the you know
Plymouth and Keen area was to trying to
build the program
oh that's great thank you
thank you very much okay thank you
I'd like to invite environmental
services for their testimony
foreign
good morning uh again for the record my
name is uh Bob Scott I'm commissioner
with the Department of Environmental
Services and uh thankfully for you I
brought the brains of our outfit uh Sue
Carlson our chief operating officer so
uh as you'll see uh in the handout
that's go that's coming your way
um
the department has a fairly wide and uh
uh diverse uh set of responsibilities
and uh you know notionally we're divided
under four uh really three divisions and
then we we internally really consider
the Commissioner's Office a division
also
um and I'll highlight uh some of the
programs that we do but I but I'll start
with we in addition to Haze and drive we
have an office at peas
uh what made many people may not be
aware of is we do have a small Fleet of
watercraft that we in in booming
material uh that we operate around Great
Bay uh especially uh as an oil supply
response uh
uh mechanism we have a coastal program
there and we'll talk a little bit later
about our shellfish program so we have a
selfish monitoring program that that
budding industry really relies on uh
also in Franklin and Laconia we have the
warrensaki River Basin which is we we I
think we're unique in the country for
such an agency as ours that we own and
operate a wastewater treatment facility
that serves 10 communities in The Lakes
Region so that's rather unique uh in
that respect we also are responsible for
the safety of the 200
2615 dams in the State uh 274 of those
are state-owned and they're in various
levels of
um I was going to say disrepair but I
don't want to be too alarmist but
there's a constant need to maintain uh
dams and other infrastructure
similarly another program that may not
be obvious that the department would
have is a spools the Pools and Spa
program and we'll talk about a position
later for that uh it and back in 2018
you know into the first year of my 10
years commissioner uh we unfortunately
had in Hampton we had an unregistered
Spa
uh cause uh Legionella or uh issue with
that impacted 15 people in Hampton uh
including a couple of deaths so that
that really was the impetus to have us
revamp that program uh so we'll talk
about that uh when we get to prioritize
needs
in addition to our our bread and butter
you know hazardous waste and Water
Resource issues uh air issues air
pollution issues uh we are also again
maybe not as obvious to folks a big part
of our annual budget is usually uh
different loans and Grant programs that
go out to the community so I've been
commissioner since 2017. we did a quick
back of the envelope uh during that time
frame over 800 million dollars has gone
to local communities for water and
wastewater infrastructure and they're
really depended on that so that's a
large that kind of pass-through is a
large large part of our budget but it's
also an important part of our workload
so those those are not just here's a
lump sum go do the what you want they
all have federal and state requirements
obviously for for auditing and by and
large they are done on a reimbursement
basis so we validate that the
engineering work has been done properly
and it's a valid uh request to be paid
uh that meets the criteria so as you may
and those are 20-year loans by and large
so for the loan so as you may imagine
those are the gift that keeps on giving
so to speak as far as workload uh is
having said that they're vital to the
communities and we view that as an
important part of our mission uh before
I leave this this slide number two
um
you see we have a total of 478 full-time
employees currently we have a 61 that's
excuse me hopefully not percent uh 61 uh
vacancies uh that's roughly 13
I just go home if that was the case uh
so so you know again so we have
engineers and scientists and uh we're we
uh if we go to the next slide I'll
continue on that that theme we do have a
great Mission which is uh protecting
Public Health in the environment and you
know oh I think that's why we only have
the 13 vacancy rate because because to
be blunt we're trying to compete with
industry for the engineers and
scientists that are out there a lot of
people come because of the mission so
we're thankful for that
so going to slide four again some of the
core functions I've kind of mentioned
already so I won't labor on that uh but
but again anywhere things that have
taken up a lot of time of late are uh
emerging contaminants uh in in water uh
the the the Good News by and large I
think the the environment has gotten
cleaner uh due to a lot of activities in
the past decades uh the bad news I
suppose is as science gets better we're
finding that in even more minute
levels that
um there are contaminants that we
weren't aware of that are causing health
issues so so the so the the goal Booth
post if you will for the agency and and
public health keeps moving and due to
science changing but that's I think
inevitable uh moving to slide five
uh again as I
kind of alluded so the contamination is
a large part of addressing that is uh
we've been very active in that I've
already mentioned we do a lot of work uh
on infrastructure uh drinking water
clean water dams uh storm water uh and
and part of that is all data management
uh to make us more efficient so annually
on average uh we we do about uh 21
000 uh permit actions and conduct over
16 000 inspections uh with 93 different
type of permits managing over 115
federal grants and 40 more than 40
dedicated funds and and in excess of 35
state laws I will say parenthetically it
seems our our responsibility emission
grows with every legislative session
since I've been here you know we
typically go in for looking for ways to
streamline and this is not again I think
it's more the goal post thing I was just
talking about but every year the
legislature gives us more
responsibilities so that's another area
where the goal post post keeps moving
moving for us but again I think it's
probably necessary but having all those
those actions I has talked about that
makes data management even more
important uh for us and and again you'll
see that in a in our efficiency budget
um
moving to slide number six uh again our
efficiency budget is uh roughly 271
million dollars so that's obviously
within the the three percent goal uh it
does represent an eight percent increase
over the 23 fiscal year 23 primarily in
the area again of uh contracts and Loans
I'll talk more about that we also within
that we've we have 14 new staff uh
broken up in areas of
programmatic work uh administrative work
and Technical staff so what what are we
talking about uh I mentioned our pools
and spots program already so we would
add we're looking at adding a position
uh due to the new requirements uh that
again were put forth after that event in
2018. uh we we have solid program staff
for solid waste emerging contaminants uh
asbestos in our state revolving Loan
Fund programs uh they're all related in
some fast and ongoing increases in
federal funding and in response to our
contaminant issues our emerging
contaminants
um
related to that I already mentioned the
importance of data management uh so the
technical staff references it was
shorthand for our business system the
analysts so we have uh different
analysts uh in our budget uh to help us
at different levels within the agency
uh and again that's so far that's proven
we already have some embedded in our
obviously you work very closely with
doit but we have some embedded within
our own programs to help facilitate
doit's work with us uh and that's really
paid dividends so that's that's why we
think we need to continue for that
so moving to the next slide slide seven
is uh again Sue Carlson was kind enough
to kind of give you a couple variations
to to give you an idea of where our
brexit lies uh really the the take home
least in my mind to this is uh we're
primarily funded out of between fees and
the infrastructure uh different funds
that's 94 of our funding only six
percent of our total budget is in uh
General funds
um so you know moving fairly quickly for
you obviously you can answer any
questions I recognize we're the last on
the list here so I know you saved the
best for last so uh I the next slide
again uh is just breaking it out a
little bit different uh and again you
see the the different loan programs
especially are a big part of what we do
whether it's I already mentioned water
infrastructure we do Bridal fields
we also again the pfas emerging
containment issue contaminant issue is
also a lot of what we do so that's 68 of
our budget is uh is passed through to
the local communities
so moving to the next slide slide number
nine again just a different different
breakout that Sue's provided for us uh
again this is by division uh by and
large you'll see uh the Water Division
accounts for if roughly 50 percent of
our operating budget I already mentioned
those pass-throughs those those major
programs are all in our Water Division
and they also probably not surprisingly
account for 53 percent of our staffing
as well uh followed by the waste
management Division and air Division and
then the the commissioner's office
so our next slide is uh analysis by cost
uh category so
um
you know this is again our efficiency
budget and I do want to focus a bit on
our prioritized needs uh as you can see
uh there's an overall increase of uh
over 19 million from 23 to 24. uh nearly
all the the increases again is in loans
and contracts
uh 10 million of that is in our clean
water when we say clean water uh it's
really jargon for the the
environmentally folks so clean why do
you think is something you drink it's no
it's actually waste water so drinking
water is something you should drink
um so clean water uh repayments uh are
are showing at 10 million dollars so why
is that so uh I'll talk about for our
prioritized needs the infrastructure
bill that Congress did is funneling a
lot of money I mentioned the 800 million
that since 2017 we've used this mostly
State revolving loan funds uh those
funds are increasing significantly under
the infrastructure bill so over the next
five years we're getting a a big
increase in in those amounts which is
very exciting uh on top of that uh the
arpa money which I'm sure you're all
familiar with uh there was a car voter
and Opera allowing those funds that went
to the at least the state government to
be used for water and wastewater
infrastructure as well so we've been
very fortunate as a state because I
think because the the are the way we
were set up and uh we already had a
surplus going into the the pandemic uh
we were able to you know I'm thankful
for move 185 million dollars into of
arpa funds to address
uh Drinking Water waste water storm
water and dams uh much needed
infrastructure work we took that money
and we leveraged that against the
traditional State revolving funds and we
were able to front load a fair amount of
work that's now going through so that
that increase is really a recognition of
let's get that money out let's leverage
what we have and we have this
infrastructure money coming on top of
that so again it's a great uh
a great opportunity for the state and
we're we're I I almost work every day
with municipalities to make sure that
they get their story out so they can
accept this monies at town meeting
because that's that's part of what many
of them have to do uh having said that
uh Federal loans also were increased by
uh one million dollars for the the
drinking water side of the srf uh from
23 to 24. uh there's a you know so a
decrease in loans for the emerging
contaminant fund which is our pfas Loan
Fund uh a couple bienniums ago uh we
were allocated uh Bond approval for up
to 50 million for pfas loans to address
contamination in the state for drinking
water uh the the reason why that showing
a decrease is because we're coming up to
that that loan cap of 50 million so we
aren't able to do as much as we had done
in past years uh we're also seeing a
contract increase primarily in our
federal Superfund program uh
let's see uh that's 6.6 million of
federal funds that were able to to
allocate and the drinking water
groundwater trust fund uh which was
came through the legislature after uh
mtbe monies from contamination came to
the state uh there's an increase for
contract work for 1.6 million for
analytical work to help those impacted
Wells and communities and finally for
salaries and benefits for 25 so you'll
see this pretty much across the board uh
you'll see those increases are a result
of the step increases and increases in
health benefit premiums
page 11 uh is again uh is an analysis
showing our efficiency budget by
category uh and again you'll see
increases in as I just mentioned in
federal funds uh primarily due to the
super fund contracts uh funding you'll
see increases uh again the 10 million I
mentioned for srf repayment loans uh in
the 1.6 for drinking water uh
trust fund for analyticals as I
mentioned so really what I wanted to
talk about after all that was the
prioritize needs
so again if I've alluded to for the the
federal infrastructure bill
uh that much of that was focused on uh
water infrastructure generally uh so
we're seeing quite a plus up and uh so a
lot of what you're seeing is is is is is
related to that but generally and I'll
go through each one real quickly is uh
we are asking for a new position for
um database work uh to help us as I
mentioned for that critical work uh
State a grant increase uh for the
Wastewater program I'll talk to that
that is not srf that's a state program
that the legislature uh likes to fund
um and then uh we'll talk about uh
additional increase for the
Winnipesaukee River Basin as I mentioned
uh and for federal funds the
infrastructure money that I felt that
I've mentioned so moving to slide 13.
uh ranked by our priority priorities uh
is our prioritized needs so again the
first as I mentioned is our new business
systems analyst to help with our our
database work so we are our constituents
are very
used to and dependent and demanding now
that we have an online presence that
they can get at environmental data
permitting information uh online that's
that's a trend that's not going away uh
and uh our our public-facing side of
that we call it the One-Stop the intent
is here's your one stop to to find your
information uh that's been an ongoing
Evolution over decades and that's a
continuous thing that needs needs
upgrading and approving uh improving so
we need help on that uh we also are
found found that we work very closely
with the environmental Bureau at the
Department of Justice and uh we we want
to fund a a new position over there so
you'll see an increase based on that and
again that's a lot of that's due to
activity for an example as I mentioned
pfas uh we're in litigation federally
with 3m the manufacturers of that the
the firefighting foam folks that that
those are just examples but those are
additional things that the Department of
Justice attorneys never had to address
before uh and and they need that time
and and Staffing to do that uh on the
positive side for
um pcbs we've they were able to get a 25
million dollar settlement in the State
uh you know with the general fund uh
with Monsanto so that's the type of work
they've been doing but they need the
staff to do that and and we want to help
increase that the state air permit
program our third prioritized needs um
uh We've we are I'll say a couple things
so that's a fee program uh but
especially as the economy we think we're
about to go into we're loath to increase
fees Most states uh augment with General
funds uh this is and historically in the
past uh bioms at least since I've been
here uh this the state has been doing
that so this is intended to uh offset uh
what would otherwise be an increase to
to mission-based fees for that program
uh priority needs number four is uh we
have under statute we have what's called
an in-stream flow program for for Rivers
uh that requires certain studies to be
done and the intent of that is is and
it's not
is probably very timely we're in
probably likely unfortunately next year
to go into year four of severe drought
in different parts of the state so the
the intent of that program is to manage
the the the use and and impacts of uh
water usage uh in our in our Rivers so
this this would allow us to a meet this
statute uh but also to do it in a more
timely manner uh I think that the
current rate will maybe get through all
the rivers in 40 years or so which is I
don't think really the intent of the
legislation
um uh the fifth uh prioritized need is I
mentioned briefly our shellfish program
uh so we were able to purchase new uh
monitoring buoys for water quality uh
for Great Bay uh data Sons is Sue always
wants me to say that uh she likes the
word
um so uh the good news is we're able to
do that but we also need they require a
periodic maintenance and we need to to
budget for that otherwise we'll have
lost that money that was so badly needed
and again the program is very successful
uh in that industry is
uh very appreciative of the program and
and uh should you need I'm sure I can
get you a lot of letters of support for
that
um
privatize need number six is
regarding stream gauges so historically
des and Department of Transportation uh
use information out of uh 2017 stream
gauges by that are maintained by the
federal USGS uh and we have a
long-standing mou that we do a
uh cost share with with DOT uh this this
biennium uh the USGS has raised the cost
by uh roughly six percent so this this
represents out of the the highway fund
uh the dot uh share that that cost
uh and again those are important
certainly to us again because uh we
managed I mentioned all those dams uh
and uh knowing the the flooding that's
happening and what's going on with the
rivers and the water bodies feeding
those dams is very important to proper
management
uh item eight for our prioritized needs
oh did I miss seven oh thank you sorry
Mike I I have my direct division
director in the background Skyline at me
uh is for solid waste we have two uh
online landfills that we there are no
responsible parties for that need uh in
order to keep them safe and and uh not
impactful to the the communities uh that
we need to fund contracts to to do at
least basic monitoring and maintenance
for those two landfills one's in Danbury
and one's in in Berlin so that's item
seven uh item eight so I go to that now
is uh is for I mentioned our
Winnipesaukee River Basin so that is a
an increase in cost for them again this
is 100 funded by the 10 member
communities uh we've been communicating
them with them regularly so this is not
a surprise to them uh but uh probably no
surprise these type of activities moving
water is a very very energy
intensive Endeavor and is probably not
lost on anybody but energy costs are are
going up quite a bit uh cost of
chemicals uh in parts so we have a
program for that the waste right
treatment facility to do upgrades that
type of thing
you'll see a lot of debt service in the
efficiency budget for this program but
the there's only so much maintenance
that can be so upgrades can be done so
what happens is now we need to obviously
the the until you do the uh upgrades the
the maintenance actually tends to
increase and the cost of those parts are
reflected in this also so so again
that's what that is for number eight uh
item number nine is I mentioned the the
the over 270 state-owned dams we're
responsible for maintenance uh one issue
is that is you can't have too much
growth on the the grass and whatnot so
so it it it could cause erosion into the
dams so uh we're asking for a slope
mower which is a special mower for the
the side slopes of the dams to to allow
us to more efficiently address that
uh item 10 is uh for stadia Grants so
stating grants is typically for
Wastewater facilities it's a state
program long-standing uh it's an after
the fat program that the legislature
again continues to fund uh that a
facility is done is done they submit to
us and it's on the order of what 20
percent
that the state then gives them after the
fact for having done that work so this
is not for number 10 is not for any new
Pro any new uh work or any new grants
being added to that list this is to
serve the the projects that have already
gone through the the GNC program process
executive Council and better prove where
we feel we have an obligation to fund
those so that's item number 10.
priorities guys need number 11. uh
is
sorry as for doit uh and again it's
primarily for software increases and as
you're probably again heard from
everybody uh even the the Microsoft
products we use have you know there's a
price to be had for those
similarly uh for for item number 12 is
uh Department of administrative services
so uh
director Gary you can ask who's your
Rockwell
um so so that's the there's their uh
portion of of our costs including about
mostly related to workman comp expenses
so then moving to slide 16.
is a
is we talked about the bipartisan
partisan infrastructure law the the bill
the infrastructure bill as I call it uh
these are related to funding increases
from that those so these again are very
impactful for the communities uh very
important to fund but that also does
increase our budget and show a need to
increase our budget so this these are by
and large programs all all through this
page uh that are you'll see over the
next five years uh for the most part and
they range from the drinking water uh
clean water and then again the number 17
is for emerging contaminants so it
doesn't pfas for those who have heard
that word is that four letter word is is
the one that gets suppressed a lot but
there are other emerging contaminants
that can fall under this and again that
goes under the the aspect I was talking
about earlier is the science changes
we're finding more things to address so
I suppose the good news on that is
Congress has allocated
we haven't actually received the money
yet but we expect on the order of 10
million dollars per year for emerging
contaminants
so almost done with our prioritized
needs so we have a lot of needs all I
can say is uh
is under page 17 uh prioritize need
number 18 is uh again through the
infrastructure Bill we received extra
monies for our dam safety program uh to
assist with them inspections again not
only for our 274 dams in the state but
it will be over 2600 dams in the state
in training so that's that's uh very
impactful money so we're happy to
hopefully be able to accept that
prioritize need 19 is for brownfields so
this is monies that have come to the
agency for site assessments for mostly
underserved communities to help
communities redevelop those sites so
um item number 20 is our Coastal
resiliency program and this is uh Monies
to help with closer projects I'll give
you an example with Culvert replacements
for instance so you know if you have an
undersized Culvert going under a road
and there's a storm uh the impacts of
that typically at the end of the day if
it's a big enough storm will be to erode
around the Culvert and take the road out
so we'd like to avoid that so in the
future we would like larger culverts to
to be sized for that so that's the type
of type of work uh that item number 20
uh is for in item 21 is again for
Combined sewer overflows in storm water
those are grants to the communities as
well a lot of work to be done there uh
this last slide is uh Sue was kind
enough again to kind of characterize uh
where our prioritized needs goes under
uh and you'll see by and large the
certainly the largest chunk uh is uh the
federal funds the infrastructure bill
money as I talk about so with that uh in
the I'm happy to answer any questions
again being the last one of the the
three days I'm curious how many
questions I'll actually get but I'm sure
you'll entertain me too yeah well thank
you uh and I and I thank you and and
Yusuf for uh
uh helping us along the way over the
last few months with all your meetings
so hopefully our questions can be kept
to a minimal but one of the things I
want to touch on is pfas given is it's
uh that the publicity it's gotten and
the money that's gone into it and I
don't know if you have this figure now
but as well if you could uh if you did
the total amount of money that has been
spent to date on the pfas program since
maybe uh going through the last budget
so from fiscal year through fiscal year
22 and then into fiscal year 23 and this
would include not only General funds but
Federal money is too including arpa
and so that's that's the first part of
the question
and then my next part of that is what
have we gotten for that money meaning is
there a way to quantify how much of the
problem has been fixed and how much is
remaining and what sort of the timeline
is to eradicate if it's even possible
the knee fast problem in New Hampshire
so I can maybe pick out the last
question part of the question first so
not that you'd want to but if you look
at a map of sampling which we do have
nationally New Hampshire is very unique
in that the whole state is represented
so we've we've done a great job of
sampling uh we were able to use drinking
water groundwater trust fund money in
2017 to help fund that initiative among
other other things so we we have we're
better positions than most States as far
as we've done a lot of testing that
doesn't mean every well in the state's
been tested but we have a better feeling
than most of where the contamination is
um
I talked about moving goal posts so we
have a state drinking water standard uh
we have one of the programs I didn't
mention in our structures we actually
have an environmental health program so
we have a toxicologist and we work with
healthy human services and we set
drinking water standards we have a
drinking water standard for pfas
EPA with the current Administration is
looking at
doing their own standard which
potentially could be an order of
magnitude even lower I don't think so
but that's still in play so that's
another area where the goal posts may
move by the way so if they if obviously
if there's a federal standard and it's
it's more stringent than what we're
doing everybody will have to comply with
that and rightly so
so having said that what we have done is
where we were aware of contamination
issues we're being able to use the funds
so off the top of my head we talked
already about the 50 million dollar Loan
program
uh we this last session we received 25
million estate Surplus to address pfas
issues uh I don't remember the number if
it's 5 or 15 million I guess probably
five out of the drinking water
groundwater trust fund so what we've
been able to and then again we're about
to receive at least 10 million a year
from the federal monies on on that so so
far to date we haven't had any federal
money directly having said that for pfas
if you
yes thank you well that's the 20 yeah
that that's true and then and then
another 25 million in our money that's
right
um on top of that so uh consider that
Federal money because it was up to the
state's discretion on where to put it uh
so so if you don't consider the upper
matter of federal money we haven't
received any federal money toward this
yet with the exception of
the state revolving loan funds do
qualify right so if you're a drinking
water system you're impacted you could
get a loan with a certain model of
forgiveness based on that and now we're
about to get at least 10 million dollars
a year so that so having said all that I
think the needs still probably uh
upstrip the the amount but we're we've
been fairly well positioned compared to
other states and that we've leaned ahead
so we know know what the problem is it's
already characterized and we've already
started spending Monies to address it a
lot of States haven't been in that place
yet
um
and I feel so for programs there are
things I wanted to highlight is not only
will be able to address for the drinking
water groundwater trust fund or or other
funds uh systems that have been impacted
and provided assistance uh we also
unique in that we're able to use some of
these funds to address private drinking
water wells so we have a Statewide
program for pfas where if you if you're
well it's been contaminated you can it's
a reimbursement program again we just
don't give money and I hope it's the
right amount and the people pocket it is
uh you can well you're up you're it's a
grant program of up to five thousand
dollars for each individual well to put
treatment on that well
having said that since we were we really
our preferred outcome is that you
connect to a public water system
then if if you're close enough to a
public water system will that program
will give you up to ten thousand dollars
to connect to that public water system
so that's available Statewide it's in
play right now there's every day there's
there's work going on in that so again
I'm not saying we've we've beat the pfas
issue but I think you'll find we are
probably better positioned than I would
argue any other state right now so
great thank you very much
um this is just a follow-up on the
prioritized need regarding the state aid
grants the Wastewater one of the largest
chunks of General funds
um I think I think so you had mentioned
that these projects have already already
been or would have already been
completed and already approved through
GNC yes
um so are these entities then you know
already counting on this money coming to
them is there a timeline that they
expect that money to come to them you
know how does that work with the
Arrangement
um the way the state grant program works
is we essentially pay 20 of their Debt
Service payments so we pay them in time
to their Debt Service payments so if the
city of Manchester is making Debt
Service payments in October and April we
will make payments to them in October
and April so if that is not funded that
impact is that they would
be responsible for
yes finding that okay and then in the
efficiency budget along the same lines
um is the efficiency budget based on for
the state aid program based on
anticipated contracts coming forward or
projects coming forward or those also
projects that have already been approved
um for the state aid program
well we were in a unique situation for
22-23 where um in the governor's budget
this accounting unit was fully funded
for existing programs
during the legislative phase this
funding was removed from the operating
budget and given back to us as a part of
hb2 from Surplus from prior years
um so it doesn't show if you were to
look actually in our operating budget
you would see for water
um we're showing a zero budget
let me tell you what the page is
uh page 61
you would see for 23 you would see a
zero budget number here
in the meantime we have been granted
through other legislation an additional
12 million dollars to make new Awards so
we are in the process during 22 and 23
actually 23 and 24. we are making new
grin Awards and that increase is
reflected for the ongoing payments in
our request for 24 and 25.
thank you
thank you very much
this concludes the governor's budget
hearings
one last note commissioner arlinghaus if
you're watching I hope you feel better
Governor's budget hearing is now
adjourned
foreign